I'm joined tonight
by Maggie Haberman
of The New York Times,
also the author of Confidence Man
The Making of Donald Trump
and the Breaking of America.
Maggie, I mean, Trump is
I feel like we've seen this movie before
where he is
promising to finally reveal
something that he has been teasing,
especially the election
fraud claims
that have never been borne out.
But you have new reporting on
what's behind
what we're expecting to see on Monday.
So Jonathan Swan, my colleague
and I reported earlier today
that aides and allies of Trump
woke up this morning
several hours
after this indictment was filed.
Accusing him
of trying to subvert the 2020 election
as part of a conspiracy
to discover
that he had posted on Twitter
social,
saying he has a major news conference
on Monday
where he's going to release a report
now that report in question
turns out to refer to a document crafted
or you know created at least in part
by Liz Herrington, a Trump
communications aide
and it refers to Georgia.
And it is going to address what she is,
I think, and whoever
she was working on it,
we're going to argue,
was widespread fraud.
Now, we know those claims
have been debunked over and over and over
Brian Kemp, the state's governor,
again, tried to denounce this today
and said the election was not stolen.
Let's move on.
The reason
the presence of Liz
Harrington is interesting
is that she is connected
to a key scene
in the documents indictment
where Trump is waving around, according
to prosecutors,
a classified document
or a secret document,
as he refers to it
that he acknowledges
he could have declassified as president.
And she is one of the women
quoted in the recording of that.
We have been told by multiple sources
that whether this actually happens
remains to be seen.
So the person who is named
and one of the other indictments
that is facing him
is now helping him respond
to this latest indictment. Correct.
And it speaks to the way that world works
right now.
A number of the people
who are around him, either
as advisers or as lawyers or,
you know, all kinds of other people
are connected to these cases
in various ways.
They are witnesses in some cases.
You know,
Rudy Giuliani is clearly coconspirator
number one in the federal indictment
against Trump
related to January six and trying to
overturn the election results.
And he is indicted in Georgia.
And so it just creates this
culture
that we've just never seen before.
There are so many co-defendants
listed in this new indictment, which,
I mean, immediately
made me think of the concern
that he has about the potential
for them to to.
I mean, there's a lot of opportunities
for people to cooperate here.
There are. And he is aware of that.
And it is one of the things that
I believe has concerned him
about this indictment.
Also, the fact that it is in state court,
it is not something he could control.
If he becomes president again,
although I think there's an argument
as to
whether a state case
would actually go forward
against the sitting president
the way this is.
But, yes, these are
this is many tentacled.
It's big.
There are a lot it's the limits.
And there's a lot of allegations in it.
And there are a lot of people
connected to it,
not all of whom are in his direct orbit.
That's the other thing to bear in mind.
Yeah.
The second half of that list
is all like Coffee County officials
who aren't directly connected to him.
Mark Meadows is, though,
I mean, to see his name
as I was reading through it
when it first got released last night,
like reading Mark Randall Meadows,
I mean, just stood out.
He hasn't been indicted
in the other cases.
He's now the first one to try to say,
well, I was just fulfilling
my official White House duties,
and that's why he's trying to get it
moved to a federal court here.
It's an argument
that I expect that former
President Trump will make to
which is that
they were acting
under the color of their jobs
and that this is something
that should belongs in federal court
because of that.
I'm not surprised to see Meadows
make that argument like you
it was
striking to see his name
in this indictment
because his name has been at the center
of this whole issue
as it's been investigated
for the last two and a half years.
But your correct.
He was not
one of the coconspirators mentioned,
as best as we could tell, who they were
in the Jack Smith indictment.
He has not been charged federally.
He has been much less of a presence
than we are used to around Donald Trump.
And he is one of the people about whom
I think
the former president
is the most concerned
about what they may or may not have said.
Certainly,
a lot of aides around Trump are concerned
about what
he may or may not have said
in various investigations. Yeah.
And also the questions of how
that affects what Jack
Smith is trying to do.
Clearly, if he's trying to use him.
The other thing, you know,
just reading through the indictment,
a lot of it is like it's things
that we knew
that had happened or what they did.
But also I was just struck
the 12 of the 161 overt acts
as funny willies referred to
them were Trump's tweets.
Yeah.
And public
and then others were public statements.
Yeah.
I mean, these are this is
look we talked about this
a lot with the tweets that they were just
things he was doing.
There was a joke about,
you know,
I was about to write a story
and Trump just tweeted it out. Right.
I mean, this was literally
they were planning all these actions
and Trump just tweeted it out.
You know,
their argument is going to be
the Trump team's that this is free speech
and that he had a right
to say all of these things.
And funny Willis, his argument
is that individual actions
don't have to be criminal on their own,
but part of a broader conspiracy,
which is what she's charged,
they are
it is why Trump's aides and lawyers
over a very long period of time
wanted him to stop tweeting
the way he did
and would like him to do less
social posting the way he is now.
It just doesn't get heard
the way it used to.
Yeah.
And he's but he's announcing
you've got this huge press conference
that your reporting is a lot of people
didn't know about.
One question that I had last night
thinking on
this is how this affects
what he's doing with the debate.
I mean, before this
we were told he's not going to be he's
not showing up to the debate
next Wednesday.
But now that he's got this time crunch
to to turn himself in
and actually show up in Fulton County,
do you think that could change
the calculus at all that he has
he has two days
until after the debate
to turn himself in?
Technically,
I think that he is likely
to stick to a plan.
There's been some discussion today
about will this be like
right after the Access
Hollywood tape
in October 2016
when he went to Saint Louis
to debate Hillary Clinton
and that that set him back on a
on a path
toward winning
but his whole campaign
was riding on that debate.
As one former aide pointed out to me
this morning correctly,
that's not the case here
in terms of the primary.
I think it could impact his impulse
to defend himself
I still think it's unlikely
that he shows up.
But again, it's him.
You never really know until he does
or doesn't do it.
You've covered
New York politics for a long time.
You've covered Rudy Giuliani
for a long time.
I mean, you have seen his him
go from this heroic figure to him today
saying he's going
to beat the fascists into the ground,
I believe was the quote that he used.
I mean,
what do you make of the fact
that the racketeering law
he used to use to prosecute members
of organized crime here in New York
is now being used against him
in Fulton County
for people who dislike Rudy Giuliani,
of which in New York
politics, and among New York voters,
New York City voters, there are many.
They feel as if this is the
ultimate irony
for people
who really liked Rudy Giuliani.
And thought he was a good mayor.
They feel as if this is a tragedy.
It is surreal hearing him
say that he's really excited
about this indictment
because I can't imagine
that he ever thought
it would be fun
or engaging or a fun fight
to be accused of racketeering.
I mean,
this is somebody who was a renowned
national figure
for busting mobsters using a similar law.
And that he has in in a quest
basically to be relevant
to stay around
former President Trump ended up
here is very upsetting
to the people who still care about him.
He's also running out of money.
I mean, I don't know about running out.
I think might be out.
He may be out.
I mean, he's putting up his apartment
here in New York
for $6.5 million in a sign of
I mean, that's not going to end here.
He has
more cases even just this week alone,
I believe,
when it comes to his wall license
and the comments he made in Georgia.
One of the ironies
right now in the situation around
Donald Trump is you will hear
some of his advisers
say he's really upset
that Rudy got indicted
or leading into this,
he was really worried about Rudy,
but not so worried
that he was going to pay
Giuliani's legal bills.
And this has been an issue over
and over and over again.
And people
who are still close to Giuliani
will try to blame
the Republican National Committee
or this former aide to Trump
or this person.
This is Trump.
According to my reporting,
it was Trump
who didn't want Giuliani paid
unless Giuliani delivered
on his promises.
And obviously, that didn't happen.
Maggie
Haberman, it's never going to end well.
Something will
everything will end eventually.
But but this this part not right now.
On that lighthearted note,
thank you so much, Maggie.